c'est une première en Europe un car
scolaire rétrophité ce véhicule
thermique a été converti à l'électrique
une pratique autorisée en France depuis
avril 2020 ainsi que dans 12 autres pays
d'Europe dès septembre 2023 il sera mis
en circulation à Amboise gérée par la
société de transport Keolis une seconde
vie plus écologique et plus économique
pour ce cas qui avait déjà roulé au
moins 5 ans reportage de Sarah gros
de l'extérieur ce car semble tout à fait
ordinaire pourtant il est le premier
véhicule thermique d'Europe reconverti
en électrique en septembre prochain il
transportera chaque jour les élèves de
la cité d'Amboise avec une autonomie de
150 km donc là on a quatre blocs
d'énergie qui sont des batteries à
lithium qui sont notre conception notre
production qu'on produit en France la 4
autres juste de l'autre côté ça fait 8
et 4 encore à l'arrière pour arriver un
total de presque 200 kilowatts de
batterie une Zoé c'est à peu près 40
système de freinage direction assistée
climatisation le tout converti en
électrique grâce au rétrofit on
décarbonate sans jetés l'intérieur du
véhicule est conservé dans sa totalité
une manière de réaliser des économies
d'énergie et sur le porte-monnaie on
estime que globalement rétrophie un
quart coûtera environ la moitié de
d'acheter un véhicule neuf aujourd'hui
on peut acheter un véhicule neuf
électrique mais d'abord il est de
production chinoise il n'y a pas
d'offres de véhicules électriques de
production européenne
l'objectif fixé par la région abandonné
totalement l'utilisation des énergies
fossiles pour ces 1754 pour le réaliser
elle prévoit un budget de 10 millions
d'euros par an nous voulons engager à
l'horizon 2028 au plus tard
0/4 produisant du carbone ça veut dire
qu'on va arrêter tout ce qui est
utilisation de l'énergie fossile on va
remplacer par du gaz qui est du gaz bio
on va remplacer par de l'hydrogène et je
recherche se conduisent et on va et
c'est une première c'est une grande
grande grande étape on va remplacer
également par des batteries électriques
quant au nombre de cas en circulation
les discussions sont toujours en cours
avec le transporteur à terme la région
prévoit d'introduire des cars sur chaque
département